así
ya profundizaremos más en las
explicaciones matemáticas pero primero
quiero enseñarles el departamento de
animación en pixar aún cuando trabajamos
con películas todo el día en una
película animada no hay un escenario así
que nuestro trabajo es sentarnos frente
a una computadora pero eso no significa
que sea aburrido nuestro trabajo demanda
mucha creatividad y por eso nos gusta
hacer que pixar sea un lugar en el que
se sienta que la creatividad florece el
departamento de animación está dividido
en diferentes zonas básicamente grupos
de oficinas cada zona tiene un estilo
diferente esta es la zona de la jungla
decorada con lianas plantas un castillo
e incluso la oficina te hace sentir que
estás en el interior de un avión que se
estrelló este es como el lugar central
de reunión para los animadores con todo
y un escenario para música en vivo yo
paso un poco de mi tiempo libre como dj
así que ayude a decorar mi parte como la
sala de vinilo con todo y tornamesas voy
a mostrarles algunas técnicas que usamos
en la animación tradicional y veremos
como eso se pasa a la computadora
primero animemos una pelota usando una
técnica conocida como animación directa
empezaré con el cuadro 1
ahora pondremos otra hoja de papel estos
apoyos nos ayudan para tenerla alineada
y aquí dibujamos el cuadro 2
ahora el cuadro 3 y ahora el cuadro 4
como pueden ver estoy dibujando en orden
un cuadro después de otro y cuando
termine escanear e iu pasaré todos estos
dibujos a la computadora para poder
reproducirlos
la animación directa funciona igual en
la computadora puedes intentarlo en la
siguiente demostración interactiva
empieza arrastrando la pelota desde
donde quieres que esté al inicio de tu
animación y después cambia al siguiente
cuadro y vuelve a arrastrar la pelota a
donde quieras solo mueve la un poco en
cada cuadro continúa repitiendo es un
cuadro a la vez y cuando terminas
presiona el botón play para ver tu
animación
ahora veamos lo que logras crear